la syrie le monde de gabrielle roy a ému
l'écrivain dominique fortier dont la
thèse de doctorat portait sur
l'écrivaine franco manitobaine non mais
j + kms heure moi j'allais pas regardé
comme une experte de gabrielle roy la
série ça m'a fait peur rim est pauvre et
j'en écoutais trois épisodes qui j'ai eu
les larmes aux yeux au moins deux trois
fois là
[Musique]
cette série de huit épisodes d'une
vingtaine de minutes grâce un portrait
de l'enfance de gabrielle roy à saint
boniface la comédienne léa qui aiment la
france le roux 10 ans brille dans le
rôle de la jeune gabrielle
[Musique]
le monde de gaprée le roi est campé dans
les années 1920 dans un manitoba où les
femmes se battait pour le droit de vote
et pour le droit de s'exprimer en
français martin franklin car la mère de
l'écrivaine on découvre l'histoire de
gabrielle roy on découvre dans les
années 1920 c'était quoi est une femme
dans les années 1920 c'est touchant on
s'en rappelle beau mais il ya des choses
qui sont importantes à savoir pourquoi
prendre encore aujourd'hui ok pourquoi
des femmes on a encore à se battre
aujourd'hui pour des choses qui sont
cinq peut-être que j'admirais trop
bernadette pour les mets vraiment cette
série qui reprend parfois les mots de
gabrielle roy et signé par la
réalisatrice acadienne renée blanchar
penser l'homme canadienne française pour
moi il ya ça dans le grand spleen ou la
grande mélancolie gabrielle roy
aujourd'hui entièrement tourné au
manitoba le monde de gabrielle roy met
en scène de nombreux acteurs d'origine
franco manitobaine dont gabrielle
d'estrées c'est un bon moment je pense
que ça démontre à quel point
l'industrie de la télé et du cinéma en
français comme en anglais se développe
depuis jamais toucher aux linges
d'église cette série d'époque est à la
fois une leçon d'histoire qu'ils ne sont
de littérature un hommage bien senti à
une des plus grande écrivaine canadienne
moi j'avais l'impression de regarder
presque des photos de famille et où on a
l'impression de reconnaître certains
visages moi j'ai retrouvé le regard et
la voix de gabrielle roy le monde de
gabrielle roy sera présenté sur le site
tou.tv dans le 16 décembre et il
pourrait y avoir une suite il avait
vraiment c'est pour moi
ici lueshe le puits mais radio-canada
montréal